في تركيا ومع اقتراب الانتخابات وبلغه
الارقام مشاهدينا يبلغ العدد الاجمالي
للناخبين 64 مليونا ومائه وثلاثه عشر الف
وتسعمائه واربعين مواطنا داخل تركيا
وخارجها يدلون باصواتهم للدقه اكثر داخل
تركيا يبلغ عدد الناخبين 60 مليون و
697,843 مواطنا موزعين على 81 ولايه اي
اكثر من 94 من اجمالي من يحق لهم التصويت
اما الناخبون المقيمون خارج تركيا فيمثلون
حوالي خمسه من اجمالي ناخبين ويبلغ عددهم
3,416 الفا وثمانيه وتسعين مواطنا لكن
السؤال لمن يصوت الناخبون الجدد البالغ
عددهم نحو خمسه ملايين ناخب تكتسب هذه
الكتله خصوصيه بالانتخابات القادمه لانها
تمثل الجيل الجديد الذي يصوت للمره الاولى
ولم يعرف كيف كانت تركيا قبل وصول حزب
العداله والتنميه للسلطه لاول مره عام
2002 وككل موسم انتخابي تستحوذ اسطنبول
على الاهتمام الاكبر ليس فقط لوزنها
الانتخابيه الاكبر داخل تركيا بل لانها
كانت بوابه وصول اردوغان للسلطه حينما
تولى رئاسه بلديتها عام 1994
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات